started
and I want to welcome everybody from all
over the world
um
I'm going to
put up this introductory
slide for the presentation and this is a
program overview for the postgraduate
program in lean Six Sigma
from the University of mass uh
Massachusetts I am Hurst Eisenberg
School of Management simply learn my
company is a delivery partner for UMass
and my name is Stuart Creek I am here
with Brian Campbell of Seven Seas
Consulting who is also one of our senior
instructors
Brian you can tell the folks about
yourself sure happy too so welcome
everyone uh yeah so Brian Campbell I
have been working with simply learn now
for gosh going on seven plus years and
I've had a lot of opportunity not just
delivering courses and content but
developing a lot of the material my
background is primarily in Project
program management with a lot of agile
transformation and that includes
leveraging technique like lean Six Sigma
so really excited to be here and um yeah
looking forward to our conversation
thank you
and our conversation is going to cover
uh we're going to be asking a few
questions along the way about you and
the audience but we'll talk about why
lean Sigma is something worth
pursuing what this program offers How It
prepares you and then we'll also talk a
little bit about past Learners and their
successes and some of the things that
the program offers you to assist you in
your success and we'll cover uh Roman
steps after the Q a so
let's talk about why lean Six Sigma
Brian
what can you tell us about
living Six Sigma and the associated
disciplines around it
yeah absolutely so this is a really
exciting area
um one of the more important emphasis is
of this space is it's actually looking
for ways in which we can increase
efficiency and therefore our output and
outcomes but also looking for ways to
reduce waste a big part of lean is
looking for sources of waste finding
ways in which you can remove that Six
Sigma is going to leverage a lot of
statistical analysis where we look at
very large data sets so we can
understand what's contributing to things
like maybe defect rates or there places
that we feel that there's some
bottlenecks constraining our processes
so I'm going to hear a lot about those
topics as well as techniques like
domainic which stands for Define measure
analyze improve and control and that's a
whole methodology that comes into play
when we're thinking about how do we
continuously improve the way in which we
deliver value as an organization yeah
and it
lean Six Sigma evolves out of the
quality
movement that really started at the end
of World War II and the history is
fascinating because
um
uh who were people who are called whiz
kids who were mostly Executives from
Ford Motor Company it helped the U.S
defense industry during the war and
after the war when the United States
Occupied Japan
one of the challenges that occupying
power had was
suing propaganda to the people so they
wanted Japanese people to own
inexpensive radios receive broadcasts
well well the issue was how do you
produce these uh high-volume low-cost
and with good quality so they brought
over a couple of guys from last name
Deming and Duran to help consult with
Japanese industry on how to improve
quality
manufacturing they came up with some
Concepts like quality is free meaning
that if you
play attention to Quality and
Manufacturing up front you'll spend much
much less on repairs and product Returns
on the back end so they were extremely
successful Japanese industry embraced
them with
great enthusiasm less so American
industry because American industry could
sell anything it made was the state of
the world economy at that point American
industry was pretty much all that was
left at a certain point in the 1950s but
um
Japanese effort for Quality transformed
made in Japan from what in the 1950s had
been a mark of inferior quality to
in the 1970s a mark of very superior
quality and once the Japanese automobile
manufacturers especially started taking
market share from us
suddenly the notion of quality in
manufacturing and quote were called
Japanese manufacturing quality
techniques took hold in the United
States but it really it came originally
from the United States it's just that
you know the prophets were not heard in
their own land so
[Music]
um
this is where our effort toward quality
really took a big push in the 1980s and
evolved into statistical process
controlling six Sigmund and a number of
the other techniques that we're looking
at today so that's a brief history
lesson but it's it gives you an idea of
how deep rooted this Pursuit is and the
demand for Quality Management continues
to soar because
um
again as we say quality is free is a
mantra that a lot of companies still
haven't
fully absorbed even this latent
age
um but as more and more
understand the value of it
the van for Quality managers increases
um so it's a lucrative
field in the United States I don't have
the statistics here for India or other
parts of the world but Glassdoor shows
the salary range for Quality Managers
from 66k at the very entry level to
159k at the top end with 100k
um being the average so it's a
good paying field
and what I'd like to do is ask you
what is stopping you
from taking lean Six Sigma certification
you're all here because you're
interested in doing that
finding out more about lean Six Sigma
and trying to give out this program so
what's kept you from doing this up till
now
and can pick more than one of these
reasons
I'm going to leave this open for another
five seconds from now for
three
two
one hit the submit button and
and really the main concern people have
in our audience today is
uh feeling that you know concerned they
do get the Practical exposure they need
to become job ready to demonstrate their
new skills
as well as finding a comprehensive
curriculum and finding a program that
fits in their life schedule so
um
we're going to be talking about this
program which is
the postgraduate program lean Six Sigma
from the University of Massachusetts at
Amherst
the Eisenberg School of Management
and
it's done in conjunction with KPMG which
is one of the powerhouse
consultant firms in the world and
it's a comprehensive curriculum we'll
get into that in a little bit
it features Hands-On projects so that
you're not just
learning academically about these skills
but you're practicing them and
demonstrating them and building a
portfolio of examples
it features online live virtual
classrooms on the same online platform
that you're doing your coursework on
so that you can learn from instructors
like Brian you can ask them questions
get their feedback
answer their quizzes and questions live
and
the rest of the time other than the
scheduled classes with the live
instructors you can do on your own time
anytime 24 7 during the week so we
figure that if you can devote 10 hours a
week or so
to the program for six months
um
fit into your lifestyle your schedule
Brian did you have a comment on
how this program
works for your students
yeah absolutely so a couple things I
noticed in the the poll there's some
folks expressed a little concern saying
hey you know will I have the Practical
experience going to demonstrate I have
these skills and what makes I think this
particular program really impactful is
it is so centered on giving you
practical Real World Experience uh your
instructors are going to come in people
like myself we're going to bring Real
World Experience into the uh discussions
and the training sessions you're going
to get a chance to kind of work in these
very Uh current contemporary
projects and apply these skills to kind
of help you build out a meaningful
portfolio that you can use to
demonstrate that not only do you
understand these Concepts but you really
know how to apply them and get results
from them so
um yeah I think those are really
important I love the fact that we've got
not just engagement with your
instructors but actually your peer group
The Others coming in the cohort of other
participants so uh really makes it for a
a really powerful Collaborative Learning
Experience which I think is a big
highlight of I'm going to interrupt you
for a second from Brian my zoom is going
to uh kick me up God I'll be back back
so okay yeah yeah so uh this happens as
you as you know it's just always the
timing right so as we wait for a
Stuart to rejoin or I get a zoom
situation address so a couple things
just want to highlight too I think some
folks who express some recording in
progress
you know how will this fit my schedule
what I particularly like about this
program is it is really designed to fit
the schedule of professionals uh those
of us that not only are busy working but
maybe have families of the
responsibilities we need to attend to so
a lot of flexibility in how you can both
take and engage the course how you learn
and apply and work on your different
projects so some important highlights
there so are you back Stuart I I am back
awesome you can see the uh yeah yeah and
so at the end of the program you receive
a a certificate you'll you'll also
receive a certificate from KPMG
um and this test that you've completed
the core courses of the program and
we'll go over what those are but
um this is uh
you UMass Amherst telling every telling
the world that you have completed this
program successfully and as as Brian and
I have pointed out you'll have examples
to back that up
you'll also receive three credits if you
want to go into an online MBA program
with the Eisenberg School of Management
you can receive three elective credits
uh toward your degree from completing
this program you'll also be able to join
the
UMass Amherst Alumni Association in
order to network and continue with
your professional development with your
peers and you'll be prepared to get
certified in lean Six Sigma both at the
green belt and black belt levels
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
UMass Amherst which is uh a 130 year old
Public University in the U.S it's one of
the top universities in the United
States and it's School of Management was
founded in 1947 tying back into that
post-world War II burst of uh energy
around
management and scientific management and
um
this postgraduate program as I mentioned
gives you the certificates access to
master classes with their faculty the
Alumni Association members membership
and the
uh green belt and black belt preparation
one of the great things about this is
that you will have on your resume you
UMass Amherst and people recognize that
name as again one of the top public
universities
in the United States and one of the top
universities in the world so very proud
to be their delivery partner
and we're also proud that KPMG is part
of this program
um so KPMG India specifically will be
participating with this program and
providing master classes and ask me
anything
and
also working with you in the Capstone
project for the end of the program so
this is a great opportunity to learn
from people with uh industry experience
insights into
the industry needs
um but of course all of our instructors
are people who we draw from the industry
as well so
um
do you have a a perspective on the
cohort of uh
instructors in this program Brian people
that you work with yeah well I think as
you kind of highlighted
um what makes this a program I think
again very impactful is it's not just
sort of an academic undertaking you're
you're getting an opportunity to connect
with folks like myself who work actively
with customers and clients so we're very
aware of what's going on in terms of
Industry Trends and effective practices
and techniques uh KPMG of course is
World recognized as one of the uh you
know most impactful Consulting companies
uh available and I mean they're really
in the thick of all the disruptions you
hear about you know all the chat GPT and
you know switch to renewable energy so
they bring so much into the conversation
just by virtue of the fact they're
working with the the companies the
organizations that are you know really
pushing the boundaries in a lot of these
areas so I think it's a great part
partnership and I think complementing it
with the simple learn structure and its
experience working with adult Learners
in particular really kind of Blends
these together really effectively
thank you and we'll we'll talk now about
how the program
uh functions How It prepares you so
Ryan and I will take you through this
step by step
skills development induction session is
pretty straightforward that's where you
learn how to use the learning management
system where to find your courses
how to get registered for the next
course in your sequence
where to take tests do projects get
completion certificate for each of these
modules
culminating in the final completion
certificate after the Capstone project
so all of that basic freshman
orientations
induction session and you move into lean
management so what are the types of
things that you're going to talk about
in management what are they going what
are folks going to learn in there yeah
so Lee management is really going to
emphasize how do we find ways to reduce
waste what are the things that are
contributing to delays to defects uh so
lean management is a combination of both
not just identifying where we might have
sources of waste that need attention but
techniques in which we can reduce and
eliminate those
um and you know it's it's sort of just a
truism all organizations have
opportunities to get better they have
waste
um and if we can find ways to reduce
that it just increases our throughput
and frankly affects the bottom line so a
lot of organizations very interested in
understanding what to what can they do
to reduce waste and get leaner as an
organization yeah and that that Harkens
back to that Mantra of quality is free
that's right that evolved into lean
management as people realize that
the sources of waste in an organization
aren't just the quality of the product
and the effects in manufacturing but
then there's also all of the other
places where time or effort is wasted or
where processes are not laid out
efficiently or where some tasks that
have been done for historical reasons
are no longer necessary that type of
thing so there's lots and lots of
opportunities and this is really a
fertile field for for
learning new skills many tab is the next
element of the program
and tell us a little bit about the use
of minitab sure minitab is um is a tool
it's a statistical tool so where it's
very strong is it pulls in a lot of data
and then you've got all sorts of
different mechanisms in which you can
identify Trends you can see uh some of
the you know averages and different ways
in which you would understand how well
is a process working what what are our
thresholds that we have the upper and
lower control limits for a process and
it's it's deviations so maybe tab is
sort of very powerful tool think of it
as sort of Excel on steroids
um really important for anyone that
needs to kind of dig into the details of
a process so
um and this is particularly important
when we're dealing with manufacturing
settings I see someone ask a question is
there application Industries like
Aerospace Transit Auto definitely in
fact
um this is really where a lot of these
techniques came from we heard you know
Stuart you're talking about sort of this
Japanese influence on this and there's a
the Toyota production system which uh
really captured a lot of these ideas and
Concepts
um is in the Auto industry space uh
Aerospace Transit where we've got lots
of transactions lots of uh things being
built very fertile ground as you pointed
out for doing some of this deeper
analysis so minitabs are going to be
really critical to kind of help with
that
then you move into
um
becoming you know prepared for your lean
Six Sigma Green Belt certification which
is the first one I actually have a
green belt from some years ago and um
so that's the the foundational
certification for lean Six Sigma can you
tell us a little bit about what that
entails yeah so uh both the the green
belt black belts are sort of different
levels within your Six Sigma
certification Journey uh the green belt
level as you might expect is sort of
your initial introduction it's going to
really test to ensure that you
understand the fundamentals between Six
Sigma some of the techniques and
practices uh we'll also get a chance to
kind of apply these in a real world
setting using
um you know real data real information
and then as we progress out to the black
belt we're actually kind of extending
that even further getting deeper into a
solution set so again having not just
the academic background on what these
techniques are but having
um coaches and instructors available to
help you build out your case studies and
show how to effectively apply these
techniques is a really important part of
this whole journey that we've got mapped
out
great
um along the way before we talk about
the Capstone project notice there are
electives along the right hand side and
these These are at no additional cost
these are things that you can take
based on your level of interest and your
commitment so you can take the module on
digital transformation and how that
applies to
uh
changes in organizations and operations
that in digital technology to reduce
waste you look at lean Six Sigma in
healthcare lean Six Sigma applications
in Information Technology
yet master classes from KPMG
Executives managers so all of those are
based on your level of Interest no
additional cost to you in the program
but all of this culminates in the
Capstone project and Capstone project is
where you tie together everything you've
learned into one
final
project to solve
industry-based product problem can you
Brian kind of describe how that how that
Capstone project module works yeah
absolutely exactly the way you described
it this is the point in which we tie it
all together
and again
um you know the partnership kpng really
helps with this they're going to bring
very current very contemporary problems
that organizations and industries are
seeing you're going to get a chance to
kind of apply all the skills techniques
and the tools you've been learning
through the program you're going to
bundle that together into this reference
project and again this is something you
can not just use to apply your skills
and kind of show that you really know
how to get the most from these
techniques but it's something you can
showcase to your existing or potential
employer and prove that you know you you
not not only know this but you can
demonstrate how to get results from it
excellent
um so that
addresses the concern that people have
about having that practical experience
because as you yes you'd talk about
before
this is something you take with you at
the end of the process and
show
how you've applied these new skills that
you've got not just the fact that you've
gotten them but how you use them and and
that includes in the various projects
that apply these different Frameworks
and tools some of these are learning
about
environment or framework or the
kind of
techniques around
uh
quality management lean six segment
product project management and then some
of these are actual uh digital tools
that you apply during the projects right
right yeah yeah the items on the left
think of these as sort of as you pointed
out process Frameworks domainic agile
which is increasingly being embraced by
uh organizations Industries across the
globe we've got the project management
Institute the PMI and their pmbok which
is the project management body of
knowledge and of course lean Six Sigma
the right hand side well tools things
like minitab that we already talked
about jira which is a really effective
Work Management platform of course our
good friend Microsoft Office Word Excel
PowerPoint and Microsoft Project really
important for helping us organize how
we're going to approach and solve some
of these problems we're uncovering
so in the course of this uh overall
program you will be
applying each of these Frameworks and
tools and many others into your
coursework as you do projects that are
assigned for each of the modules and
projects uh
the end of the process so for example
here are some of the projects you do
along the way
um several examples you might for Best
Buy the U.S discount
electronics and appliance store
you look at how lean Six Sigma works
with their Innovation initiatives uh you
look at the Mac methodology to look at
how you would improve the air preheater
performance you're looking at an actual
challenge of how a product works and
where you would look for opportunities
to improve its performance and get it
back to design values you can look at
lean operations in the service business
casinos which is
hospitality and entertainment and you
can look at improving the quality
process for a non-profit
um
such as the akshaya Patra foundation so
these are some examples of real world
challenges that you'll be asked to look
at how you would approach these problems
and apply different tools and Frameworks
to come up with your solution
these are sprinkled throughout the
different uh modules of the program is
that correct
yes exactly you'll get a chance to kind
of get exposed to different problem sets
like this as you just highlighted
um you know these are not just sort of
real world problems uh but they're from
companies you should recognize companies
you can say yeah those are marquee names
that are known around the the world and
uh and it's again a real opportunity to
kind of understand here's challenges
they're facing how can you use these
techniques to address these challenges
and problems and the and the idea also
to give you an idea of the variety of
Industries and environments that they
can be used in so we talked a little bit
about the Capstone and and again the
Capstone lets you pick
the project that interests you from six
potential challenges
um and you work on that for several
weeks with weekly check-ins with your
instructor so
again can you kind of describe what that
check-in process looks like right right
and and that's a really important part
of this because we don't want
um you know students kind of having to
get to work independently on this we
want to give them feedback we want to
make sure they're getting support and
guidance as they kind of take these
techniques apply them so um the the
whole intent behind this and as you
pointed out you get to choose you find
one of these six Capstone projects that
interest you maybe it's because you work
in that space that domain or just
something you're kind of interested in
and want to learn a little bit more
about
um and once you begin that you're
partnering with your instructor uh
someone like myself who's looking at
what your what approach you're taking
the techniques or checking in with you
they're looking at your progress giving
you feedback so you can kind of really
strengthen your Capstone project
response and really make look at that
showcase that you can bring with you
when you want to look at maybe New
Opportunities and say well here's a
demonstration of how I've applied these
techniques and practices
it's a it's fairly much your final exam
for the entire program and it's
evaluated for
for credit and um
here's a couple of examples out of the
six you can look at
in the telecommunition
Telecommunications domain you you can
look at go to meeting and there
um customer satisfaction
initiatives to find out how they can
improve customer satisfaction scores and
and reduce What's called dsat the
dissatisfaction score
so where would you look in
that for the challenges they are
creating the dissatisfactions and how
would you and address those and then on
the other side we have a healthcare
domain where
a hospital needs to deal with a critical
issue of
time it takes to transport patients to
the hospital and into care which can be
a matter of life and death so you know
you look at
the application of lean Six Sigma and
processes around it
these are not just business challenges
these are challenges that have real
impact on
human life so
um
just like I said six different domains
you can choose from these are examples
of
uh I'm before I uh ask Brian to share
his screen and take you through what the
learning management system looks like I
want to mention the fact that we have
um
several senior staff at uh
you may ask who are overseeing the
program Who oversee the curriculum and
its delivery including uh
Professor Robinson and Dr Birch and they
um
make sure that this is a UMass Amherst
program delivered by simply learn so
it's a
how they manage
to put their name on that certificate a
test to
putting their reputation behind your
education so
just wanted to point that out did you
have any
other comment about that yeah you know
just the fact that um you got some of
these uh most well-recognized industry
thought leaders who you're going to get
a chance to uh to interact with and who
have been very instrumental in
developing this course material and this
whole uh learning uh Journey here so
yeah I think this is this is great you
know Alan Robson you know very well
recognized very well respected and uh
similarly when we've got uh folks like
Michelle Birch involved
maybe this should give you a lot of
confidence that you've got some of the
best and brightest uh we're going to be
spending time with you kind of helping
you learn these ideas and Concepts
okay at this point I'm going to stop
sharing my screen and I'm going to
invite you Brian
yeah you have permission to do that okay
let's uh take a look
yeah so I hope you can see my screen is
that coming up for everyone
okay
yeah so um what we want to do is spend a
little time talking about the learning
management system that you'll be using
when you're working in this program so
uh one of the the real strengths of
Simply learn is that over it's many many
years of delivering high quality adult
learning on a huge range of different
topics is that they have developed I
think one of the strongest if not the
best learning management platforms that
are available in the industry right now
so I'd use this extensively they put a
great deal of time and effort in making
sure that this is a very user-friendly
very intuitive system for you to access
the information you need to support your
your learning needs so um so you come to
the the site we're going to spend a
little time on a umn business analytics
boot camp just to give you a flavor of
what the experience looks like you'll
see that when you come in into your
program you'll have a collection of
cards that essentially represent the
different courses that you have this is
the Core curriculum
so we saw
um Stuart spent some time kind of
showing those stair steps that get you
to the Capstone project you'd see the
same things here each one of these are
clickable so uh we'll start with this
introduction to data analytics uh
everything in the platform uses a
similar
um look and feel so you're going to feel
it you know very very familiar as you're
navigating from course to course same
layout makes it kind of easy to to get
around
um every one of the courses is supported
by a video learning set of modules just
like you're seeing on the screen here uh
so this is kind of like having a virtual
instructor right in front of you going
through the content on the right hand
side you can see we can navigate across
different lessons notice that we've got
some progress bars that indicate how far
along uh you've gone in those particular
sections so you've got lots of
opportunities to kind of go back and
maybe relearn or re-familiarize yourself
with uh different pieces of information
um each one of the modules are also
going to come with some kind of
assessment that you can test your
knowledge and how well you've retained
what you've learned and there are always
reference materials you can download the
content that you're looking at if you're
if you prefer that learning style I know
sometimes I like to print things out and
take some notes on them well that's
that's an option you have available
don't forget that this is uh this
platform's accessible not just through a
PC or computer but through your tablet
through your phone so if you've got a
some time at work maybe you got a lunch
hour and you want to apply some of that
time to kind of watching some of the
videos learning you have that available
as an option so you'll get a chance to
kind of track your progress through uh
all the the course offerings uh in
addition these are all complemented by
live courses that you can take so
um of course you know we all enjoying it
a lot of benefit from hearing and
instructor talking directly to us so
those options are going to be available
to you through the program and by the
end there might be some circumstances or
maybe the schedule doesn't fit with you
uh perfectly or you just want to learn a
little bit more independently so you've
got this mechanism that you can you can
look at as well we have the electives as
well you heard Stuart mention that in
addition to the Core Curriculum there's
a collection of different master classes
and other topics you can spend time with
so you'll find those in the electives
section of the learning management
system and when you're all said and done
you'll get your access to different
program certificates so in addition to
this certificate for the postgraduate
program itself you're getting a whole
bunch of other companion certificates so
when you leave this program you're going
to have quite a bit to fill up both your
resume and your LinkedIn profile that
you can again showcase your skills and
knowledge in these areas
Stuart what else do you want me to spend
a little time on
okay
um let's talk about the community great
yeah yeah that's a really important
place to spend a little bit of time so
simple learn has a a very rich very
Vibrant Community that they have uh sort
of nurtured over delivering uh tens of
thousands of courses over the years of
existence so we can click on this
community
um icon it's going to bring you into the
simpleton uh Community you've got a
number of different forums there will be
one established for your cohort so that
basically means all the students joining
in this particular uh program at the
same time you'll have one place that you
can all access to post questions and
help one another out as you're learning
and studying these are all monitored by
not just our simple learn
7x24 customer support team but uh the
instructors and the uh
um the Learners and uh coaches that are
part of the program so you'll always
have easy access to get some support and
help if you need it and it's also just a
great place to kind of build that that
network of contexts right you know a
really important part of your learning
experience is is connecting with some
peers and I found from you know 30 years
ago when I got my MBA uh still in touch
with a lot of the people I uh got my MBA
through so this is a great place for you
to invest some time and really build
that sense of community as you're taking
the program
and as you touched on it the 24x7
support means that if you're working on
a project at three o'clock in the
morning because you happen to be up late
and uh just decided this was a good time
for you to
do that work
um and you run into some type of Doubt
or a blocker or a dead end
you have the ability to reach out to the
employment support team even if your
instructor may be asleep somebody will
be there to help you with issue so
um
let's
do you have anything else that you
wanted to talk about in terms of
learning management system well you know
I think the highlights for me is just
the fact that this is a very intuitive
easy to navigate uh product
um the other thing all the content in it
is very well and very highly produced
um so you're gonna really have I think a
really positive learning experience uh
and then that that's that's pulling not
just from you know University of Amherst
and it's sort of proven track record but
also what citizenart has been doing for
a very long time
so I think this makes it a really good
uh place for uh people interested in
kind of expanding and extending their uh
their career options is uh is looking at
this particular program thank you
all right I'm going to go ahead and move
on in the presentation here
so
also if Zoom kicks me off because I'm
re-sharing my screen I will be back
does that sometimes as we've already
seen
so we're now looking at the availability
and prerequisites for the program you do
and here it goes here comes Zoom I'll be
right back okay oh no yeah so we've got
a few uh a few questions that are
popping it into this about you know can
I get credit for these classes Etc
definitely uh a lot of these classes are
going to be uh if you've got an existing
you know for example a PMP certification
yes you can use this coursework uh for
those credits and uh and you can
absolutely use a lot of the courses
you're taking if you want to take other
programs uh in the future so uh so all
of us that you're seeing right here is
is very sort of you know core and
foundational for for many other
university colleges
yes well I'm still here I'm going to go
through this uh you have a bachelor's
degree as a requirement for this program
so it can be in any discipline it does
not have to be technological
uh digital discipline or
engineering discipline
um you can come from a non-programming
background because anything you need to
learn with respect to
programming techniques or uh software
very little of that really in the uh
this program but the things you need to
learn about using the tools will teach
you you do have to come in with at least
five years of work experience so this is
a program for people who have been in
formal work for some time
typically people who 've been out of
university for five years working
history
um although the the five years of work
experience can be in any field so
with that I'm going to ask the question
uh how much experience do you have
hopefully it won't kick me out in the
middle of the poll
I'm going to leave this open for just
another 10 seconds since it's pretty
straightforward
and I'll close in five four three two
one
so
the large majority of our audience are
people with more than five years of
experience or
almost that level
um and
share that with you
take a look at that and for those of you
who have less experience there may be
other
programs or courses that you can take
that will
help you along your journey
um
this one in particular does have those
prerequisites so
let's talk about past Learners and their
successes
this is something we're very proud of
because when you learn in this program
you're going to learn with cohorts of
people coming in from other companies
from the industry so don't work
alongside people from companies that you
know a smattering of those include
Amazon Intel Shell Oil
AIG Insurance Tata consultancy
Accenture consultancies uh people coming
from all different backgrounds
Information Technology but also large
cohort from manufacturing from banking
financial institutions uh Consulting
Health Care is actually the biggest
sector and then a whole range of other
Industries so these are people you know
what do you seeing in the classes that
you conduct Brian in terms of the
variety of people in the backgrounds
that they come from right you know what
um it's interesting bring that up
because you can see here this has quite
a uh pretty broad distribution and uh
first off you know that's because this
is applicable to every industry and as
you can see from some of the companies
there uh any large uh organization is
going to be very interested in bringing
in people with skills in lean Six Sigma
um second part of this though is that
you know that cohort that you'll be
working with is going to bring their
experiences from these other Industries
and other organizations and that really
kind of enriches the whole learning
experience I found it uh always kind of
really refreshing I tend to work a lot
in the healthcare oil and gas space just
just the nature of uh the industries
that I've been focusing last few years
so it's always really interesting when
you hear you know someone who's got more
of a manufacturing background who's
sharing some of their experiences or
someone's a little more it oriented so I
think that kind of enriches the whole
experience and and look at these names
here I mean Amazon Intel shell Tata
Accenture
um you know these are marquee
organizations these are all great
companies to to get you know
opportunities with and to see your
career grow with him
and just to clarify because you
mentioned large companies it's the
medium and small companies also need
efficiency
startups maybe more so you're right
so we have a few testimonials you can
see more of these on our uh our website
but for now I just wanted to point out
you know
Kiran who who was extremely happy with
the
training that he received in the
curriculum the staff support
um you have hemia who is uh
looking to to leverage us to improve his
career we have
Rosemary who
earned PMI ACP certification learned
about minitab uh digital transformation
also earned her green belt and black
belt certificates so she's very excited
um
who completed the program and earned a
30 salary hike within his current
organization so
that's a the kind of results that we
hope that we will help you achieve
through this program
um do you have any other C stories from
uh students Brian yeah you know what it
I think this really sums it up I mean
there's two parts of this one is most of
the participants Learners they just
enjoy learning they've kind of expanded
their Horizons they have new knowledge
that can be really fulfilling but let's
face it look at adisha 30 increase in
your salary like who isn't going to be
happy with that right that's sort of a
nice return on that investment
to help you achieve that one of the
things that simply learn provides uh in
addition as part of this program
specifically in India and in the US
we don't currently offer it outside of
those countries but we are working on
that but within those countries we do
offer you job assist Services through
IIM jobs in India and talent Inc and us
um for everybody who's involved of
course you build up your portfolio as
we've described with the projects that
you do in Capstone
and we also provided a series of
different webinars and career
development webinars that are free and
available to you on a lifelong basis
regardless of where you are but
specifically in India and in us we offer
access to the respective job portals of
those organizations
and we offer also resume review and
rewrite service and interview prep
Services both of which are extremely
important because resumes today have to
be written so that an AI bot and review
the content and match you up with the
job description because that'll happen
before any human sees your resume and
then the resume still has to have a
visual and
textual appeal to
the humans who will see it once the AI
bot filters it through and passes it on
so
uh it's important to work with somebody
who can balance those two objectives and
then the same thing with the one-on-one
interviews because
there's so many interviews that you go
through in the process of finding a new
job or finding a promotion within your
company range from a telephone screens
with HR recruiters and and uh
recruiters and HR departments I should
say and then you you can move on to the
technical interviews with your potential
new peers and supervisor who want to
know can you do the work
then move on to the
cultural fit interviews where people
want to know what's your work ethic are
you good team player do you fit in with
the culture of the organization all of
those interviews have different flavors
to them
different ways that you want to present
yourself in practicing each of those
with a live
interview prep helper is a really
valuable thing so
we're very proud that we can offer that
at least to our U.S and Indian learners
um
So based on what Brian and I have shared
with you so far are you interested
and enrolling in this program
I'll leave this open for about 15
seconds
it's a yes or no question it's pretty
straightforward
I'll close this in 10.
and then five four three
two one
so over 80 percent of the audience is
interested in enrolling and I'm going to
um
share that with you so you can see that
right and I'm going to
describe that process for you enrollment
steps are straightforward you submit an
application by emailing us and I'm going
to put the email address into
the chat
you have that available but it's ask us
at simply learn.net
once you do that we'll reach out to you
to verify your degree we'll reach out to
you to verify your work history and take
a look at your aptitude with regard to
the
other aspects in your interest in Six
Sigma see in the chat now you've got
that email address
the next induction session happens
May 1st coming right up and
the next classes
formally start on June 10th
classes are usually scheduled either
four hours Sunday four hours four hours
Saturday four hour Sunday
or the some of our programs are
scheduled two hours a weeknight for four
nights a week but
um
again those are the only scheduled times
that you need to arrange to be in the
program the rest of the time you can do
it on your own
uh whatever
hours that you want to devote to it the
reason we tell you to hurry in limited
seats are available is because unlike a
massively open online course
this isn't something where we can feed
as
self-study videos to as many people as
sign up this is something where
instructors have to give individualized
attention to the cohort members so we
try to limit the cohort sizes to about
25 to 30 people maximum so that you have
the ability to interact with your
instructor and they can give you the
time and attention that you need to be
successful
um so we recommend that you contact us
quickly if you're interested in getting
into this uh cohort that starts with the
classes in June
here are the program fees so the price
in the U.S is
22.99 dollars
which can be financed at 203 a month go
monthly installments or in India the
price is 97 999 rupee
just shy of one lock and then uh 83.71
repeat a month for Emi financing
we recommend a couple of things one if
you're not in India or the United States
consult with the learning Accounts at uh
ask us at simplylearn.net to find out
what the price is in your local country
you'll also probably find that out on
the website and I will share that link
in a moment
um but
the other thing we remind you is if you
have an employer who has a
benefit of tuition reimbursement
we recommend you contact them about that
because they may be able to assist you
with the program cost as well that would
be dependent on your particular
employer's policies
so for those of you who said you are
interested
or did that
um for those of you who uh said you were
interested
how soon would you want to start are you
looking to start in that
cohort that begins in May uh with the
classes starting in June or are you
looking a little farther down the road
I'll leave this open for another
five seconds since it's a pretty
straightforward question four three
two one hit that submit button
here are the results so about a third of
our audience want to get started either
the June classes or maybe the July
August cohort
um for those of you looking further down
the road we recommend that you also
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
and we'll keep you in touch with future
cohort dates also answer any uh
questions you may still have about the
the program so
we recommend all of you give us a
you know
so gone through that process we can go
into the questions and the answers now
and
we have a number of questions that came
in the Q a and you might want to take a
look at those Brian sure yeah we'll also
take a look into the chat and see what's
going on but yeah some some good ones
here I think first one uh yeah I think
someone Bella was saying hey I need this
lean Six Sigma to help boost my career
absolutely
how different is postgraduate program
project management which also includes a
lean six Sigler Greenbelt certification
uh they're definitely going to have some
commonalities so I think as we pointed
out lean Six Sigma is something to be
used both in project management and
outside of that but there's also going
to be a bunch of deeper look at
techniques particularly on statistical
analysis using minitab as an example so
you're going to find it's it's kind of
going a little further in those areas
whereas project Management's going to
put a little bit more emphasis on how do
I build schedules and budget and manage
risks so
um but some commonalities on lean Six
Sigma
uh let's see what else we have some
questions about schedule for live
classes that's all going to be available
online at the simply learned site and
when the program gets started you'll get
a very easy sign up process on when the
line live courses are going to occur so
it makes it pretty uh pretty
straightforward I do want to mention uh
one from the chat about resources for
people who aren't uh don't qualify for
the uh
five years of experience oh yes yeah so
there are other programs Within simply
learn website you can take a look at for
uh some component courses
towards this
do you wanna
yes everybody to take a look at those
absolutely there's so many in fact uh
one of the strengths is simply learned
it's got this very exhaustive catalog in
somebody to Perry so that that's an
excellent addition
and
uh that especially applies to people who
are students who can look at some of our
other offerings that are you know
tailored for people earlier in their
careers
um
what are the examination modes this one
we're looking at here oh okay
yeah I mean a couple things about the
the examinations
um for the certification exams
themselves uh these are after you know
often sort of a proctored exam
experience uh they will be delivered
through either the project management
Institute or
um asq or whoever might be facilitating
and managing that so uh these days Stu
and I might remember the days where we
had to physically go in and write these
exams in a test center uh the good news
is now we have a lot of online options
so you should be able to do this from uh
in your home but um you'll get a lot of
guidance on what those exam
certification processes will look like
all the courses are oriented around
ensuring that you can successfully pass
these exams so that's an important
emphasis of everything that's delivered
right all of the
assessments done for the coursework
within the learning platform the
learning management system all the
assessments at the end of the courses
and that type of thing are done online
within the learning management system
but as Brian correctly identifies
some of these courses are designed so
that you can then go to the outside
certification body and their exam so
their policies are on online versus
offline
dependent on their
particular setup uh we have a question
for somebody that asks if
since this is called postgraduate you
have to have a bachelor's degree I still
have six credit hours to complete my
bachelor's degree in management if
you're six credit hours away
um the policy that we have is that you
can enroll in a program of this type
if you are
going to complete your degree before you
complete this program so if you will
have your degree awarded before the six
months
of the program are up then that you'll
meet that requirement the other
requirement of course is you still have
to have the five years of experience uh
so you need to consider that in your
decision as well uh how can Six Sigma
help in project management that's right
up here your alley brands of your ass
yeah yeah definitely so uh particularly
lean Six Sigma so again you know as a
project manager
um you're always on the lookout for
inefficiencies uh things that could
delay your schedule your budget so a lot
of these techniques and practices uh fit
very comfortably into your project
management delivery so um all the
techniques and practices we're going to
learn about how to identify ways how to
identify bottlenecks in your process are
going to be very instrumental in the
project management domain so it's got a
very natural fit in fact if you took
your project management certification
you're going to be spending a lot of
time on some of these very same Concepts
um
combine a couple questions together uh
what are the steps in the belt levels is
there a yellow yellow belt before the
green
um or a white belt before the yellow
um uh what are the actual steps in lean
Sigma classification system and the
second part is you know
um do you have to have a strong
statistical background to be able to do
the minute tab part of this oh yeah so
so um answer the first question actually
there is just the green and the black at
least these are sort of the very well
recognized ones you might come across a
few different organizations that have
some some more entry level ones
um but yeah green and black are the
conventional ways in which we recognize
lean Sigma expertise and then do we need
a statistical background no in fact
that's gonna be taught to you through
the courses now I'm not gonna lie and
say uh there's not some math involved so
if you're not really comfortable with
math that's not your strong suit
um you are going to be using some math
but again you know the the focus on this
this should be very accessible if you've
got an undergraduate degree I don't
think you're going to come across
anything that you shouldn't be uh
comfortable with managing and and
learning yeah and you'll have the
software software provided to you
through the learning management system
so yes while you're enrolled in the
course you'll have access to the
software tools you need um
and is I think we're at almost we're at
the time limit but I want to ask what's
one last question is the program good
for a construction project background
oh absolutely yeah construction uh first
off you know construction is one of the
biggest industries in the world around
us uh and of course there's so much
opportunity for improvement right
reducing waste looking for ways in which
you can get better at work particularly
you know in the commercial uh building
space you absolutely want to find ways
in which you get more efficient more
effective get your buildings built
faster so you can get you know earn
money faster all those things so yes
definitely very applicable to the
construction industry okay and we have
many more questions but we're out of
time so I apologize for the folks whose
questions we couldn't get to
um but you can contact uh ask us at
simplylearn.net for some of those or
um reach out to me or Brian
um and you can find Brian on LinkedIn
yeah
Brian Campbell Seven Seas Consulting I
will uh now ask one last question of our
audience
and
um forgive me if I get booted off one
last time but I'm going to try this
again fingers across
exactly
um
yeah it's going to do it okay
all right and if you see the question uh
maybe give some thought to this do you
need some assistance with your
enrollment recording stop recording in
progress okay here comes you brought me
back
but I'm gonna ask this one last question
which is
uh would you like us to reach out to you
uh for assistance
and also if you would like to receive a
digital certificate of attendance proof
of attendance
uh for this session night please today
tonight please reach out through this
answer yes and we'll
send you a proof of attendance for this
particular session today
but your e we will follow up with an
email to you regardless uh everyone will
receive a follow-up email with a link to
the recording of this session
as well as information on
getting enrolled and I am going to put
into as we're
as you're looking at the result of the
poll I am going to put into the
chat the email address one more time
along with the URL of the
program page on our website so you'll
get a chance
to that link
there it is in the chat
I want to
at this point I think everyone
especially Brian
thank you yeah for his generosity with
his time and his knowledge
thank you very much for that Brian yeah
thank you great session
and I want to thank everybody else I
hope to welcome the simply learning
community
and with University of Massachusetts
Amherst and that concludes our webinar
take care everyone